at the college level
they came in and they took these 18 year
old minds and they turned them from
being decent hopefully somewhat
productive members of society or at
least future productive members of
society and they turn them into mindless
woke robots but you got to get them
before College because now we know this
is leaking into literally kindergarten
and first grade with this gender
nonsense and confusing kids about what
sex they are and gender and all of that
nonsense so you know what's going on
right here in Florida will run DeSantis
is passing some laws passing some laws
not to stifles free speech but to make
sure that places of Education are about
education and not indoctrination here he
is talking about this AP
African-American history course that was
going to be pushed in the Florida
schools that he has made sure is not
going to get there not because he
doesn't want African-American history
taught or an honest assessment of this
of slavery but he does not want politics
and a dishonest assessment pushed on
every kid going through our school
system here in the State of Florida our
education standards not only don't
prevent but they require teaching black
history all the important things that's
part of our Core Curriculum this was a
separate course on top of that for
advanced placement credit and the issue
is we have guidelines and standards in
Florida we want education not
indoctrination if you fall on the side
of indoctrination we're going to decline
if it's education then we will do this
course so when I heard it didn't meet
the standards I figured yeah they may be
doing Syracuse it's way more than that
this course on black history what are
one what's one of the lessons about
queer Theory now who would say that an
important part of black history is queer
theory that is somebody pushing an
agenda on our kids and so when you look
to see they have stuff about
intersectionality abolishing prisons
that's a political agenda and so we're
on that's the wrong alongside of the
line for Florida standards we believe in
teaching kids facts and how to think but
we don't believe they should have an
agenda imposed on them when you try to
use black history to shoehorn in queer
Theory you are clearly trying to use
that for political purposes so they're
trying to push queer theory in
African-American AP courses here so you
go into this AAP class so you're in 11th
or 12th grade you think you're going to
learn about African-American history and
I believe we have American history but
of course we can look at moments that
are important to specific segments of
society they're really important to
everybody but we could obviously he as
de Santa said right up top we're not
we're not trying to not teach about
slavery or give an honest assessment of
history but you go into that class
thinking you're going to learn about say
slavery and next thing you know you find
out that Harriet Tubman was bi-curious
and the Underground Railroad
there's some other lesbian joke there
you get it guys you get it enough with
this enough it's enough
[Music]